There's yet another creature that roams Cuba's underworld.
It emerges mostly at night...
...and stays close to its hole.
But once a year, triggered by rain,...
...the females all emerge en masse.
Millions of female red crabs march together...
...in one of the largest mass migrations in the world.
This marathon can cover nearly ten kilometers and take days.
Especially if they take a wrong turn.
So, where are they going and why?
They're heading for the Caribbean sea with one purpose in mind.
These may be air - breathing land crabs,...
...but they still need water for one thing:...
...to breed.
Each crab is carrying a pouch of precious eggs.
And now, she has to cast them adrift...
...without letting herself be swept away.
Once the eggs hit water,...
...they hatch into tiny larvae.
And then about a month's time,...
...they'll climb back ashore to start their life on land.